okay so I just watched that new Edgar
Allan Poe movie the pale blue eye and I
had no idea there was so much Scandal
and drama in his early life not that
this movie is exactly historically
accurate though I will say there's a lot
more in this film than what meets the
pale blue eye so it's pretty much common
knowledge that Christian Bale has some
super weird work habits and apparently
he denies being a method actor which
might be the least believable thing he's
ever said I like that I like looking in
the mirror and going I ain't there I
mean whether you buy that or not he has
had to undergo some serious physical and
mental transformations to get into
character for the pale blue eye it seems
like the biggest Body Mod for Christian
was growing a beard while he may not be
everyone's favorite cup of tea Christian
seems to have found his collaborative
soulmate with pale blue eyes director
Scott Cooper I love working with Scott
and this was something that we've been
talking about since like 2012. they
actually have a long history of
collaboration including the film's
hostiles and Out of the Furnace actually
in fact Cooper seems to be such a
Christian Bale Fanboy that he's actually
admitted to well I'll just let him tell
you this is the third film that I've
written expressly for Christian he tends
to embody my characters in ways that
frankly others couldn't okay does anyone
else remember high school English class
something about a raven or was it a cat
anyway obviously this movie wouldn't be
complete without Edgar Allan Poe played
by Harry melling who honestly looks like
an actual person from the 1800s it's
really our true introduction to Edgar
Allan Poe's when we really get a sense
of who Poe is and also he played this
guy in Harry Potter wow throwback make
it move
foreign anyway pale blue eye isn't the
first time Poe has been portrayed on the
Silver Screen but it may be the most
important performance of him considering
melling's consistent praise I'd love to
see him keep playing poke right keep
doing the older Poe we know it's she
after that it seems like this whole
movie is just a bunch of Edgar Allan Poe
stands getting together to make some
real thought-provoking Cinema boys let
me just focus on one and that would be
Harry melick because Harry is just a
really superb actor oh Christian that's
super sweet so this movie was actually
based on the novel The Pale Blue Eye
written by Louis Bayard in 2003. that
was what it all came from Louis Bayard I
asked him who wrote probably white the
book even the author of the book this
film was based on couldn't get enough of
the guy the events that take place in
this film Inspire him to become the
writer that we have known so the film
doesn't give us as intimate a view of
Poe's inner psyche as the novel does but
it comes pretty darn close it's
something where you can have zero
knowledgeable and just enjoy it for a
detective thriller so whether you're a
die-hard Poe fan or just a cash Netflix
subscriber there's definitely something
for everyone in this cinematic
Masterpiece sorry I'm done with the
British accent I swear I am pleased to
report I have successfully decoded your
message and speaking of things
pretending to be British this film was
pretty much exclusively shot in
Pennsylvania actually I guess that's
pretty historically accurate for this
historically inaccurate account of Poe's
formative years sorry I'm getting ahead
of myself Edgar Allan Poe really did go
to West Point Military Academy though
and I have to admit this film looks
incredible there are so many beautiful
winter shots and cozy old buildings
something that's absolutely gorgeous to
look at even if it is a mystery thriller
the pale blue eyes gives some serious
hashtag Cottage core vibes or well
actually on second thought maybe it's
more dark Academia I wanted to film this
in a way that felt almost black and
white but in color so that it felt
austere a bunch of the film's Interior
scenes were actually shot in this really
cool place called the old economy
village located in Slippery Rock
Pennsylvania oh and just a quick side
note what's with these weird names of
old American towns like there's actually
a place called Truth or Consequences in
New Mexico anyway back to the old
economy Village much like our boy Edgar
Allan Poe this place was no stranger to
mystery and Intrigue in the early 1800s
it was actually the home of the Harmony
Society a religious community in the
1800s with a charismatic leader and an
obsession with Utopia yeah this place
sounded like a straight-up cult where
are the facts where are the simple facts
the truth so what did you guys think of
this film did it scare you was melling's
performance compelling maybe even Oscar
worthy let us know in the comments and
be sure to like And subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the things